[Música]
el acuerdo sobre el techo de la deuda
está ahora en manos del senado que debe
aprobarlo antes del 5 de junio para
evitar que el país entre en impago en la
noche del miércoles la cámara de
representantes y ha valido el texto
nayib bukele cumple cuatro años en la
presidencia de El Salvador y es el
mandatario más popular de América Latina
a pesar de las denuncias en su contra
por violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
en el marco de su guerra contra las
pandillas
en la Cumbre de la comunidad política
Europea el presidente francés Emmanuel
macron reafirmó el compromiso de Francia
con el envío de más ayuda militar a kiaz
mientras vuelo dimirdsky pidió el
ingreso de su país a la otan
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mazeu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos en Estados Unidos porque el
senado tiene ahora en sus manos la
responsabilidad de que el país no entre
en impago la cámara alta dispone de
tiempo hasta el 5 de junio para aprobar
la ley que suspende el techo de la deuda
hasta 2025 a cambio de recortes en el
gasto público ayer la cámara de
representantes ya ha valido el texto
desde Washington Cristóbal Vázquez nos
amplió
el líder de La minoría republicana en la
cámara alta es decir en el senado dijo
incluso que la votación se podría dar
hoy mismo lo que están tratando de hacer
que es el líder demócrata en el senado
de hecho es el líder del senado teniendo
en cuenta que tiene la mayoría del
partido demócrata en la cámara alta Pues
están tratando negociar con
algunos senadores que han dicho que van
a tratar de hacer enmiendas a este
proyecto de ley que fue aprobado en la
cámara de representante anoche y
entonces lo que quieren Precisamente es
que estas enmiendas no demoren el
proceso teniendo en cuenta que no hay
tiempo para poder gastar en debates de
pequeñas enmiendas en este proyecto
entonces de hecho hoy en la plenaria del
senado dijo que en las sesiones van a
continuar abiertas hasta que se haga la
votación y pues hay esperanzas de que
sea hoy mismo a más tardar mañana
viernes que haya ya el voto definitivo
lo que dicen analistas legislativos acá
en Washington es que el paso por el
senado es muy positivo teniendo en
cuenta que ya los dos partidos han
expresado su apoyo públicamente a este
proyecto de ley es decir lo único que
falta es tratar de animar esas asperezas
en las enmiendas que quieren hacer
algunos senadores para que se vote se
vote y el proyecto de ley vaya a la mesa
del presidente White y hoy uno de junio
el presidente de El Salvador nayib
bukele completa cuatro años en el poder
y mientras es el mandatario más popular
de la región por reducir la criminalidad
en un país que llegó a ser el más
inseguro del mundo organizaciones
internacionales lo acusan de masivas
violaciones contra los Derechos Humanos
con un estilo fresco y la promesa de
hacer una política distinta nayib bukele
asumió Hace cuatro años la presidencia
de El Salvador ustedes decidirán cómo
quieren ser gobernados
porque lo del pueblo al pueblo bukele Ha
logrado captar la atención de la
comunidad internacional por sus
controversiales políticas y decisiones
calificadas como autoritarias una de
ellas se registró el 9 de febrero de
2020 cuando el mandatario tomó junto con
el ejército la asamblea legislativa tras
la negativa de los diputados para
aprobar la financiación de su plan de
seguridad hasta que finalmente lo
consiguió el plan de control territorial
es la estrategia insignia del mandatario
para acabar con las pandillas del país
que controlaban el 80% del territorio y
para 2015 llevó a El Salvador a tener la
tasa a domicilios más alta del mundo
queda aprobado el proyecto de decreto lo
que hizo que el 27 de marzo de 2022 El
Congreso aprobará por pedido de bukele
un régimen de excepción vigente hasta la
fecha como respuesta a una escalada de
violencia que en un solo día dejó 62
muertos la medida permite capturas sin
orden judicial e incluso a aquellos que
tengan tatuajes
además el presidente inauguró una mega
cárcel con capacidad para albergar cerca
de 40.000 detenidos el gobierno difunde
con orgullo imágenes de los presos
descalzos Encadenados y ordenados
perfectamente
según bukele hasta el 10 de mayo el país
completó 365 días no continuos sin
homicidios medidas que cuentan con más
del 90% de la aprobación Popular según
encuestas pero con el rechazo de la
comunidad internacional la gente le está
diciendo al gobierno aquí estamos y no
estamos de acuerdo en ciertas políticas
que usted está haciendo anteriormente
era difícil sobrevivir
a uno no sabía si volvía a llegar a
regresar a la casa otra vez la
popularidad de bukele quedaría
demostrada en las urnas en 2024 tras
anunciar su intención de lanzarse por
reelección a pesar de ser
inconstitucional Según la ley
salvadoreña
y vamos a Chile porque este jueves el
presidente Gabriel borich compareció
ante el congreso para rendir cuentas
sobre sus 15 meses de mandato el
mandatario pronunció el discurso más
largo de un presidente ante legislativo
desde el restablecimiento de la
democracia en Chile más de tres horas de
alocución que nos desgrana nuestra
corresponsal Patricia Luna
el presidente chileno Gabriel borics
realizó su segunda Cuenta pública en lo
que fue el discurso más largo de la
historia desde el retorno a la
democracia y en la que evaluó las
consecuciones de su año y casi tres
meses de mandato Como por ejemplo la
reducción de la jornada laboral a 40
horas semanales el incremento
significativo del salario mínimo la
persecución a los deudores de alimentos
aquellas personas que no pagan los
alimentos de sus hijos a sus exparejas y
también el royalti minero para el futuro
trazó tres líneas derechos sociales en
las que destacan medidas como tratar de
lograr la reducción de un 40% de las
listas de espera en la salud pública o
la tratar de lograr la equidad en los
salarios entre hombres y mujeres otra
línea fue la seguridad en la que destacó
el uso de tecnología para perseguir el
crimen organizado pero también aspectos
como restricciones a los narcos
funerales o los narco mausoleos que se
construyen en el país también última
línea de desarrollo sostenible en la que
destacaron aspectos estratégicos de la
economía del país como el litio las
energías limpias o el hidrógeno verde el
presidente hizo un gran llamado a la
unidad para lograr una nueva reforma
tributaria con la que financiar muchas
de las reformas sociales prometidas por
su gobierno y también finalmente lograr
Y tratar de alcanzar al acuerdos para
que los chilenos puedan tener pensiones
mucho más altas de las que perciben en
la actualidad una de las demandas de más
larga Data de la ciudadanía chilena y el
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva se volvió a presentar dispuesto
y disponible para mediar la paz entre
Ucrania y Rusia pero recordemos que
durante el g7 el mandatario brasileño
citó abuelo dimirselensky en los
pasillos de la Cumbre pero el líder
ucraniano no acudió al encuentro de
hecho en la reunión de las siete
potencias uno de los objetivos era que
países no alineados como Brasil o India
se acercarán a kiev sin embargo Lula
mantiene su postura de Solicitar a ambos
bandos que se abran al diálogo
no acontecerá nada pasará mientras
Ucrania y Rusia No tomen la decisión de
que quieren la paz
por lo tanto Brasil es parte de un grupo
de países que quieren permanecer
neutrales para que podamos Construir la
posibilidad del fin de la guerra
y la guerra en Ucrania fue uno de los
temas centrales en moldavia donde 50
líderes se reunieron en la Cumbre de la
comunidad política Europea el presidente
francés Emmanuel macron reafirmó el
compromiso de París con la ayuda militar
a kiev y en su turno voló que la otan
permita el ingreso de Ucrania a la
alianza militar
el escenario no dejaba de ser simbólico
voltao ya vecino ucraniano y al este de
las fronteras de la Unión Europea
recibió a los líderes del viejo
continente entre ellos bolo y mirt
selenski el presidente ucraniano aseguró
que recibió apoyo en materia de
seguridad de los asistentes a la Cumbre
pero pidió ir más allá
estoy agradecido con todos nuestros
socios pero los Patriots son patreots
con respecto a la coalición de aviones
para nosotros es importante que Estados
Unidos desempeña el papel principal ya
que los f-16 son sus aviones
la comunidad política europea fue una
iniciativa del presidente francés
Emanuel ma en su segunda reunión el
mandatario galo se mostró optimista con
el compromiso de los países europeos y
reiteró su apoyo a Ucrania
esta mañana me reuní con el presidente e
hicimos una declaración común afirmando
el apoyo en términos de preparar la
contrao
la mirada se puso más al sur del
continente en los balcanes la atención
es palpable entre kosovo y Serbia y
makon se ofreció como mediador junto con
el canciller olafones nos reunimos con
el presidente kosovo Osmani y luego con
el presidente de Serbia bussius y
Acabamos de terminar una reunión con los
cuatro juntos reuniendo a ambos
presidentes alrededor de la mesa y
pedimos decisiones claras para la
próxima semana
sobre la mesa quedó la ampliación de la
Unión Europea muchos son los pedidos de
ingreso como el del anfitrión moldavia y
el de Ucrania unos nuevos integrantes
según las palabras de macoon requerirán
repensar la estructura del bloque de los
vamos ahora a senegal donde estallaron
protestas en contra de la condena al
popular líder opositor usman songo por
corrupción de menores la justicia lo
sentencia a dos años de cárcel y lo
inhabilita de Cara a las presidenciales
de 2024 un escenario para el que el
líder nacionalista y antioccidental se
perfilaba como el principal opositor al
actual presidente maquisal
en la capital senegalesa da Carla ira
era perceptible El veredicto del caso
político judicial más delicado del país
volvió a encender las calles los jueces
condenaron a usmansonco principal figura
de la oposición a dos años de prisión
por corrupción de menores pena
suficiente para inhabilitarlo a
presentarse a las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024
decenas de sus partidarios protestaron
contra El veredicto el opositor fue
acusado por aylisar antiguo empleada de
un salón de masajes de repetidas
violaciones entre diciembre de 2020 y
febrero de 2021 En aquel momento ella
tenía 21 años sonko Fue absuelto de los
cargos de violación sin embargo sus
abogados ya han anunciado que utilizarán
todos los medios a su alcance para
anular el veredicto
es una condena extremadamente dura dos
años de cárcel para usmansonco por el
delito de corrupción de jóvenes está
claro que vamos a utilizar los medios a
nuestro alcance para impugnar esta
decisión
lo que está en juego en este caso es
tanto penal como político son cuesta en
una batalla sin cuartel con el
presidente maquisal y desde el inicio de
sus procedimientos judiciales en febrero
de 2021 el opositor ha denunciado un
complot para apartarle de la carrera
presidencial desde 2021 una veintena de
civiles han muerto en disturbios
relacionados con la situación de sonco
El bando presidencial lo acusa de tener
planes insurgentes y como cada inicio de
junio Jerusalén vio desfilar la marcha
del orgullo y de la tolerancia 30.000
personas marcharon por la ciudad en
defensa de los Derechos lgbt la cifra
más alta desde 2016 en una jornada que
este año se caracterizó por un amplio
despliegue policial nos amplía nuestro
corresponsal Federico cuevarberena
con las consignas de Orgullo y
tolerancia a la comunidad lgbtq de
Jerusalén realiza su marcha anual la
primera bajo el actual gobierno israelí
de extrema derecha y Ultra religioso los
participantes defienden masivamente sus
derechos Más allá de que en los últimos
días crecieron las amenazas en línea y
de que paradójicamente quien supervisa
la seguridad del evento es el ministro
extremista está marvingivir que en el
pasado abogado por la cancelación de la
marcha un motivo más para asistir a la
cita la verdad que es una fecha muy
importante especialmente acá en
Jerusalén estamos frente a un gobierno
de ultraderecha donde esta marcha es
súper importante porque están Todo el
tiempo intentando sacarnos nuestros
derechos las cosas que el gobierno dice
sobre las personas rgbtiq legitima a
aquellos que nos discriminan en el lugar
de trabajo en las calles y sabemos que
en Israel en los últimos meses la
discriminación en la sociedad ha
empeorado mucho unos 2000 policías se
movilizaron para garantizar la seguridad
del desfile mientras A pocas cuadras de
aquí grupo de extrema derecha realizan
una contra marcha con lemas fóbicos y
violentos la marcha también fue
repudiada por el grupo islamista
palestino jamás amenazas y actitudes que
no amedrentan a quienes luchan por su
lugar en una ciudad marcada por el
conservadurismo religioso ciudades como
Jerusalén no son amigables con la
comunidad lgbtiq si no no se presentamos
y les mostramos que somos parte de la
ciudad y que demandamos ser vistos
estamos en riesgo de que nos quiten
nuestros derechos
la atmósfera se está volviendo más
peligrosa la gente se siente insegura y
es un impacto directo del gobierno
actual mientras su mensaje sea que no no
se reconocen o que nos desaprueban
el último reporte de la organización
aguda para la comunidad lgbtq reveló que
en 2022 se duplicaron las denuncias de
agresiones en el área de Jerusalén
respecto de 2021 una muestra más de que
todavía queda un largo camino por
recorrer hacia la igualdad y la no
violencia contra el colectivo aquí en la
ciudad Santa
y con este reporte de Jerusalén llegamos
al final de esta edición pero recuerden
pueden ampliar toda esta y más
información en France 24 y France 24.com
gracias por su atención enseguida
volvemos
[Música]